ونقل موقعه بلومبرج عن المبعوث الامريكي
الى ايران روبرت مالي ان اداره رئيس جوبر
ستركز بشان ايران على ملفات اساسيه منها
امدادات الاسلحه الى روسيا بدلا من
المحادثه المتوقفه لاحياء الاتفاق النووي
الايراني عسكريا في ظهران جمع نائبه وزير
الدفاع الروسيه الكسندر ومينا وقائد
الاركان الايرانيه اللواء محمد باقري في
اطار اجتماع الرابع للجنه المشتركه
للتعاون العسكريه هذا واكد باقر على ضروره
ترسيخ التعاون الايراني والروسي في اطار
الاهداف والمصالح الوطنيه
من اجل احدى السلام والاستقرار في المنطقه
على حد تعبير
وينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بكسيات العميده
لنبدا اولا بتقييم المشهد بناء علم على ما
يروج من تنسيق ايراني روسيا عسكري
خديجه هناك عمليه ماسسه لهذا الاتفاق يعني
المسيرات الايرانيه شاهدناها في اجواء
اوكرانيا تقصف البنا التحتيه طاقه مياه
وحتى تدفئه وما شابه فزن هناك تحالف
استراتيجي بدا يترجم على ارض الواقع هي
يبدا القرار بالفعل السياسي من اعلى القمه
الهرمين ان كان في ايران او في روسيا
وبالتالي يتدرج الى عمليه الماسه من
التدريب الى التعاون الى التبادل حتى الى
الدعم السياسي بالمشروع النووي الايراني
يبدو اليوم ان هذا هو استكمال لمرحله
سابقه ويبدو ان التحالف اصبح استراتيجيا
همم والهدف دائما هو همم
التعاون الروسي الايراني
اليوم حدود التعاونه حدود المصلحه ماذا
تريد ايران من هذا التعاون وماذا تريد
روسيا من هذا التعاون روسيا اليوم هي
بحاجه ماسه الى هذا السلاح بسبب نقص فاذا
هي دوله عظمى تستورد من دوله اقليميه اخرى
عظمى تستورد سلاح وقد تستورد ايضا من
كوريا الشماليه فاذا دائما هناك الاثمان
التي ستدفع من في مكان ما وقد تدفع
الاثمان ان كان على صعيد ال تي 5 بلس 1
الاتفاق النووي او حتى قد تطفى على المسرح
السوري وهذا امر اصبح تقريبا معروفا وحتى
يمكن مساعده ايران بالمعنى التقنيه
بالتكنولوجيا النوويه وغيرها من التقنيه
اخر المعدات الامريكيه التي وصلت الى
بولندا ما طبيعتها وما الذي يمكن ان تحدثه
كتغيير
يعني دائما هناك اعاده انتشار لهذه القوات
يعني هناك مزيد من السلاح الامريكي في من
الجبهه الممتده من دول البلقيه وحتى
بولندا خاصه بولندا تعتبر هي المدخل
الاساسي الى اوكرانيا وبالتالي راينا منذ
فتره سقوط صاروخين هذا الامر احيا اعاده
الدفاعات الجويه اعاده رسم العقيده
العسكريه خديجه يعني كيفيه القتال
بالطريقه الجديده وبالتالي هذا امر يعتبر
بالمعنى العسكري وحتى الدبلوماسيه هو عامل
رابع له روسيه كي لا تذهب الى اي مغامره
ضد اي دوله منتميه الى النيته شكرا لك
العميد اللي يسالنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من بيروت شكرا